- Hey, Hannah.
- Hey.
- So, I'm making a DIY video to make stuff
to make my house look less shitty.
- Do you know how?
- I don't.
- I was wondering if you could help me.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- Do you wanna make a DIY video with me?
- DI, why not?
- Let's do it.
Good high five.
(laughing).
- Hey.
- Hey, you guys.
Today we're gonna show you how
to make $150 pillows for
around 20 bucks each.
Oh, no, oh, no.
- Down down.
- Throw pillows are the easiest
way to transform a couch.
- It's something that can tie your room
together without having
to spend a ton of money.
But first, I gotta see
what I'm working with.
Can we just like check
out the space first?
- Yeah, actually we passed
my house, like a couple.
Okay.
Welcome to my home.
This is my house.
So, I just moved here about a month ago.
- A month?
- Yeah.
And I want this to be my
first adult apartment.
I love this place, I just kind of
inherited all of this shitty furniture.
- I think definitely, these couches
are kind of a bland color.
- [Zach] I can't afford a new couch,
but I can afford new pillows.
- I wanna do this
technique called Shibori.
It's a method of folding fabric,
and then you're gonna use
indigo dye to color it.
I feel like with a little pop of color,
because your walls are white,
I think it's really gonna do a lot.
Are these gonna stay?
- Yeah, they're Samuri swords.
- Do you play with them?
- You don't play with
them, they're decorative,
and they're also for fighting.
This is my bookshelf, it's built-in.
- You wanna show me your toys?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- This is Lando Calrissian,
this is Marty McFly.
This is a novelization of
the Rugrats Passover episode.
- And it was a dollar.
- Yeah, it was a dollar.
It's a steal.
This is Mr Bacon's Big Adventure.
It's basically Candy Land with meat.
I have all five of the Spice
in my Pocket Spice Girl books.
My favorite word is existentialism.
I can't say it, and I'm not
quite sure what it means.
- This kind of reminds me
of a dangerous children's room right now.
- Thank you.
- We'll focus on the pillows,
and then maybe see where
we can go from there.
But we need to do
something about this lamp.
Did you find it on the sidewalk?
- So, for this project, what do we need?
- We need an indigo dye
kit, five gallon bucket,
rubber bands, Popsicle
sticks, clothes pins,
and some heavy duty rubber gloves.
It covers more of your arm.
I like your shade of pink.
- Thank you, I love the shade of blue.
It matches you're hair.
- The important thing with indigo dye is
you use 100% white cotton.
- Just an all cotton white
case, four bucks each.
So the pillows $10 at IKEA.
- So first things first,
four gallons of warm water.
We have our reducing agents,
pour both of those in.
And the indigo.
- Wait, what's a reducing agent?
- That's just gonna help
it adhere to the fabric.
When you're dying something,
you need a reducing agent.
- Cool, dope.
Oh no, oh no.
- It does not smell very good.
- Oh, it's awful, smells
like sweaty gym socks.
- That's why we're outside.
Mix that all together, let
it sit for a little bit.
- It's like a witch's caldron.
- It is like potions class, right.
Let's cover this up
and set it to the side.
- Oh that's heavy.
- Oh careful.
- Oh my god, I spilled on myself already.
- Are you ready to start folding fabric?
- So we got a few different
folding techniques right.
- We have so many pillow cases
and they were so inexpensive
I say we just try a few
Do you need help?
- No.
The most basic fold is an accordion fold.
It goes like eeh-eeh-eeh.
So you're gonna do one fold over.
Flip it and fold it the other way.
And again so from this, you do a square.
You're gonna accordian this way.
- Okay.
- This is gonna be the
most frustrating part
of the process, making
sure your folds are even.
- Your boy Zach over
here fuckin' nailed it.
- Beginner's luck.
So we're gonna use these wooden blocks.
These wooden blocks press
where you don't want
the dye to sink it.
Rubber band these together nice and tight.
- Look how cute they are.
- Don't they look adorable,
they're like little packages of joy.
- Om nom nom
- But the great thing
is you don't really know
if it's gonna be good or bad.
You just do it.
- You're so much more positive
than my normal friends.
(laughs)
It's 'cause I have kids.
So from this, there's so
much you can do, triangles.
- I love triangles.
- We're gonna fold it in
an accordion triangle.
If you wanna get really fancy
- I do.
- Do some like clothes
pins clipped around it.
Let's do circles.
This is the easiest
tie you're going to do.
So you're gonna find
the middle, poke it up.
So you have this little clump right here.
You're gonna take your rubber band.
You can do one large circle
or a bunch of little ones,
and they both look really really cool.
- It's like a little ghost.
What do you think his name would be?
- Percy, no, too fancy.
- Let's get to dippin'.
- So these are gonna go in.
We're gonna submerge them
very slowly so the air bubbles
completely out of them as
we're sticking 'em down.
- In you go you ghost.
- No!
- Not me!
If they're floating to
the surface a little bit,
you can just give 'em a
good spin every so often.
- And this is why you wear the gloves.
- We're gonna keep these in
for one to three minutes.
We're gonna take them out,
hang 'em for 20 minutes
and allow them to oxidize.
- Whoa, it's so green.
- Watch it change.
We're gonna squeeze it out,
'cause we just don't want
indigo dye dripping all over the place.
- Whoa and look at the difference between
this one and that one.
It's only been out for a
few seconds, but you can see
the gradient of how it oxidizes over time.
I mean, look at that.
- We'll do this twice, and
then fully rinse them out,
and then see what happens here.
So one to three minutes, out
for 20, repeat, rinse, done.
- What are we gonna do for 20 minutes?
(dramatic music)
- It is pretty cool, right?
(swords clanging)
- Yeah, it's kind of fun.
- Okay so now we are
rinsing off the cases.
- This is like the most annoying process
where you're just like
rinsing and squeezing.
When it starts to run clear, we're good.
- Man you got a really work it.
- This is yours.
- Oh no, I think you should
do it, I'm too nervous.
- Ready?
- Yeah.
Whoa!
That's beautiful.
So we do this with all of
them now, we rinse the out
and they we put this in the washer dryer?
- Yup.
- With like soap and everything.
- Laundry detergent, yeah.
- Okay.
- That's it.
I have an itch right now.
- Yeah, here use my elbow.
- Okay, that actually worked, thank you.
- Teamwork.
All right so it's about three weeks later.
Why three weeks?
We're busy, deal with it.
I have seen the pillows
because I live here,
but Hannah, you have not.
- You haven't invited
me over, what the heck?
I've been a little nervous
to see how they turn out.
It's kind of hit and miss,
you never know what you're gonna get.
- Oh also, the pillows
actually inspired me to do
a little more decorating.
- Oh my gosh.
- So, but.
- Wait, I'm so proud of you though.
- Thank you.
I think we've talked enough on this stoop.
This is not even my stoop,
it's a stranger's stoop.
- He might come out.
- Yeah, we should go.
- Let's go.
- Cut.
(jazz music)
Welcome.
- Oh my gosh!
- Did we do goo?
- Oh my gosh.
I feel like breathing a hug
sigh of relief right now.
The room has so much color.
It looks brighter.
- It's brighter.
- Yeah and I mean these
couches don't look so dull.
Oh my gosh.
(high fives)
The pillows helped brighten up the room
and they made me realize
what kind of carpet
I should get.
The carpet made me realize
like what I should put on the walls.
I know it sounds silly
but this one piece kinda
helped me just figure
out what everything else
should look like.
- I just can't get over how
each of the patterns looked.
And it kind of has these darker patches.
- Which I love, the imperfections
just become details.
- Oh my gosh.
So online these shibori
pillows can cost up to $150.
- Now it's time to find out
what did we actually spend?
(upbeat music)
- Okay.
- 2.28
- plus 15.48
- Hold on, I lost my calculator.
- Okay, start it over.
- Hold on.
$14.11 a pillow.
Confetti effect.
- Under budget.
- Not only that, you
can make up to 15 things
with one batch.
So that price will come down and down.
And shibori t-shirt, it shrunk.
It's now a child's shirt.
- You're a child size.
- Thank you.
I guess that's it, huh.
- Now that we've transformed
the couches and the walls.
- You wanna keep goin'?
- There's a lot more we can do.
Starting with that table.
- What's wrong with the table?
DIY difficulty out of 10.
- Three.
- What's a one?
- Popsicle stick frames?
- No, that's way harder, the glue slips.
- Oh my god.
- So there's Sabrina the
Teenage Witch, PC game.
- Wait, can I borrow this sometime?
This is so cool.
And it has Salem on the front.
- Dang it's not even like scratched.